this episode is supported by 23andme
growing up I looked so different than my
siblings that I honestly thought I was
adopted so today I have brought my
sister in and made her take at 23 me DNA
tests so we can know for sure if we are
actually related if I'm adopted and if
I'm not how similar our ancestry is
given that we look pretty different
all right so we are both together we've
both taken the 23 meat kit how are you
feeling Jim oh I'm so excited
what do you think that we're gonna be
very similar interesting the exact same
totally different I think we're gonna be
not exactly the same but really similar
so I think Mitch and I look alike in
some respects and in other respects I
think that we don't but a lot of people
think that we do not look alike
oftentimes actually they'll say that
they think that Greg from ASAP science
is my brother and he's the one I'm
related to and not Mitch so it's called
23 me because we all have 23 pairs of
chromosomes and it's a personal genetic
service that looks into your DNA to tell
you about the regions of the world your
ancestors come from and can tell you
about physical traits sleep patterns and
even how your DNA impacts things like
muscle composition and caffeine
consumption both Kim and I use the kit
to submit a spit sample and then waited
to get our report online okay so I've
actually already I did this before with
Greg on this channel so we're gonna like
refresh what my ancestry is before we
dive into yours okay so this is the man
that kind of shows a breakdown of what I
am so I'm 63 percent European okay but
then you can see all these colorful
spots all over the other map when Greg
did this it was a little really just all
in one area
I'm 99.99% European
so you're white so I've got to feel
really like proud that I was like more
diverse so that gives you a general
sense of my background and what I am I'm
nervous because I'm like I don't really
know if it's an identical I don't know
I'm scared oh I see color I see lots of
colors oh my gosh
Africa oh my gosh yours is like
really beautiful I would have fully
thought that she was like almost
entirely of European descent this tells
us where your ancestors came from and
how long ago your mostly that is so cool
yeah so you can see like a British and
South Asian are like pretty recent
dressed you literally have family from
and still living in India and we
obviously probably have relatives still
in Britain and Europe to compare exactly
I have 62.2% European in me and you have
sixty 1.9% the fact that I'm more
European than Kim I wouldn't have
guessed that and I know that it's kind
of silly just a base it on the
assumption of like skin tone and we're
not that far apart and skin tone like
that was like definitely a big shock
then South Asian you are 21.2% and I'm
twenty three point five which seems like
pretty much the same and it's
interesting that we probably got those
same deems from when you tell people
that you are part Indian or South Asian
like did you tell people that did they
don't like yeah people do and there
sometimes people be like oh now I see
you don't look Indian oh you're more
East Asian and Native American than a
Chinese I find I would never expect it
it is so crazy because I bet yeah like I
think people like could guess nut could
guess it for me but I don't think anyone
they probably would have thought a
hundred percent Scandinavian like and
then you have 0.2 percent sub-saharan
African and I have zero percent I am
definitely the most surprised that I am
point two percent sub-saharan African
broadly North East African and broadly
west but why is that in my DNA not yours
I don't understand that if Kim and Mitch
both inherit fifty percent from their
mom's egg and fifty percent from their
dad sperm shouldn't their DNA be the
same not exactly one way to think about
DNA is as a bunch of different colored
beads obviously midget Kim's parents
have complex DNA but let's pretend their
mums is 100 percent Indian and their dad
is 100 percent
if this were the case kim would get a
random half of her mum speeds and a
random half of her dad speeds Mitch will
get another random half as you can see
it's a different mix but each is still
50/50 British and India let's change it
to their mom having a bunch of different
backgrounds that make up her ancestry
and let's leave their dads the same Kim
might have DNA that looks like this
while Mitch's might look like this as
you can see there is some overlap but
Kim has some ancestry that isn't
represented in Mitch at all and before
your mom and dad passed down their
chromosomes something happened during
the infamous process of meiosis each
parents own chromosomes swap some DNA
amongst pairs therefore every egg and
every sperm is unique I wonder if our
other brothers and our parents did it we
might even find out like there's other
regions of the world that we do have
ancestry from okay so we have been told
that there are gonna be results about
like musical pitch musicality do you
think that one of us is more musical
than the other no I feel like you are I
think you probably I don't think your
perfect pitch cuz I feel like you'd know
if you did you never told me you are
more likely to be able to match a
musical pitch and I am about a 50/50
percent chance of being able to match a
musical pitch
so I'm worries based on genetics and
other factors Kim is more likely to
match a musical pitch that Mitch but how
exactly did 23 and me figure this out
whether you're seeing professionally or
just in the shower
matching musical pitch is a lot of work
for your brain first when your ear hears
a sound the brain must quickly identify
the pitch second the brain decides which
vocal muscles are needed to produce a
matching sound third the brain then
listens to your own voice and your brain
determines if it matches the original
sound this complex process is linked to
over 500 genetic markers associated with
this specific trait comparatively the
genetic trait that allows you to smell a
distinct smell in your urine after you
eat asparagus is only related to one
genetic marker back to pitch 23andme
uses the 500-plus markers along
with other factors like age and sex to
create a model so this model does
predict that Kim is genetically more
likely than Mitch to have perfect pitch
but that doesn't officially mean one has
better pitch than the other do you have
a fear of heights that's the next we're
gonna look at yeah you do
oh I'm absolutely terrified oh wow okay
I've gone skydiving I've like published
things that I don't really think I'm
scared of them even though sometimes I'm
like you didn't get that feeling when
you're like go jump off you are more
likely than average to be afraid of
heights and I'm less likely than average
for your phrase isn't that's so cool
we both have at least a little universe
which may actually be an understatement
because I have a lot of universe and I
did have a lot of okay so 23 me also has
like a share and compare section where
we can literally connect and then
compare directly our genes so what if
someone would have told you okay so you
and I share 43.4%
of our DNA that's it that's still a lot
like identical twins would share 100
bison right so we there's no way we
could have 100 the average for siblings
is around 50% so we're slightly lower
but still definitely siblings so I guess
I am officially not adopted though now
I'm realizing I literally could have
just asked him because she was there
when I was born
did you have fun I had so much fun I
think that the whole experience like
almost makes me feel closer to my
siblings because you're kind of finding
out a story that really is only shared
between you and the people you're
closest to so it was like a fun little
thing that I couldn't have experienced
with really very many other people in
this world if you're interested in doing
this for your loved ones or yourself
there are seasonal promotions on right
now we'll put links in the description
but go to 23 me comm slash ASAP to check
it out and get your own kit make sure
you check out Kim's channel ask him
really I'll put links to there as well
otherwise supposed to see you next time
bye